tonight a warning for parents from a
grieving mother about how quickly things
can turn when a child is left by a pool
unsupervised that mother speaking
exclusively to victoria saha after
tragically losing her own son
brian and denise it's only been 72 hours
since little oliver passed away in
california while on a trip with his dad
his mom says oliver was left alone when
he fell in the pool this incident a
tragic reminder for parents to always be
alert when it comes to pool safety
happy birthday
literally my sunshine angelica richards
describing her five-year-old son oliver
the best way possible
never
in a million years did i think last time
i held him was going to be the last time
i would hold him richards says oliver
was going away with his dad and stepmom
to bakersfield california to stay at his
grandma's house he wakes up i'm going to
you know california but that excitement
was cut short when tragedy kicked in
richards says oliver was left
unsupervised around the pool no one
realized he fell in until it was too
late he must have fell in the pool
when they went to check on him
they found him at the bottom of the pool
richards was also in california with her
fiance the two rushed to oliver's side
at the hospital they pretty much told us
that
we just have to wait until he's ready to
go richard says although she's grieving
for her little boy there's anger because
this tragedy was completely preventable
there was
no gate around the pool somebody needs
to be watching them but hopes her story
will spare another family from going
through the same heartache i just don't
want his
memory to
fade away
richards has set up a gofundme account
to help bring oliver's body back to las
vegas and lay him to rest that
information is up on our website at
8newsnow.com
bakersfield police department is still
continuing their investigation regarding
this